but it's fair to say that relations
between the UK and Albania have been a
bit fraught in recent months with
thousands of young albanians crossing
the channel last year and accusations
that they're coming for economic reasons
but on a visit to meet Rishi sunak
yesterday Albania's prime minister said
he wants all our balians to feel safe
and honored here in the UK and I'm
pleased to say that the Albanian prime
minister Eddie Rama joins me now a very
good morning to you thanks so much
so tell us a little bit about your talks
with the prime minister with Rashid
sunak yesterday what was the main
message that you wanted to put across to
him
of course the British Albanian relations
are of a very highly strategic
importance and they touched the lowest
point in history
since we have come out of communism
because of that
rhetoric that has
put all the Albanian community in
Britain in under a very very heavy
pressure but in the meantime while I
made I think clearly the point about the
rhetoric our relation is not at all just
about that it's about much more and uh
we had a very constructive meeting with
the Prime Minister and I must say that
both on the side of what has been
important to him uh to tackle the uh the
criminal networks uh and on the side of
what is important for both on
building up a very very strong relation
we have made important progress and I
must say that finally on the side of
Downing Street we have been heard and
there is not any more only words but
also deeds in putting together in place
during task force to crackle to crack
down the criminal networks which is of
course something Albania has always
wanted and we have always been Keen to
cooperate with Britain you talked about
the rhetoric that you were unhappy about
you particularly commented on Zoella
bratham and the home secretaries
language you called it disgraceful so
tell us a little bit about what it was
that you objected to and and what you
think that did to relations uh listen I
I again I think I've made my point very
clear and I don't want to repeat it
again and again because it would be not
not right vis-a-vis the much broader
picture and much deeper relation between
Albania and Britain and it would not be
also Fair let's say to insist on that
while we are having very important signs
of regret and of embarrassment that are
let's say enough at this point I hope
very much that this will not be repeated
anymore and that the Albanian Community
here will be really honored for what it
is because one thing is to put
in the in the in the spot under the
under the spot of the attention the the
boats and the criminals and all that is
disturbing but the other thing is to
never forget that albanians here are
doing uh grades and they are helping and
contributing for Britain to be a better
place yesterday I was I got out of the
hotel with the people that uh that take
care of my security and I hear from the
sky Eddie Eddie Eddie and I
I'm looking up and there there was uh uh
there was a construction site and there
were three people on the top dressed uh
as cons as constructing constructing
workers that were all the three
albanians so obedience here are working
in construction companies they'll bring
us here are nursing your elderly people
business here cooking so improving the
British kitchen I must say and they are
even singing to you so uh let alone the
academics and the students and it has
been so unfair to them to put them under
such a pressure but in the same time
they are a very strong base to build
something very important so you really
want to stress the important role that
albanians play in our communities but
there is concern about the number who
are arriving in small boats which I
doubt you discussed with the Prime
Minister
um they made up albanians made up 28 a
small boat arrivals last year how
concerned are you about that listen it's
a trend in all the countries that have
come out of the dark periods of
Communism and that are trying to catch
up with what has always been our Horizon
looking uh to the developed countries
and you cannot stop young people dream
and hope so because okay Albania is one
case but there are other cases for
example Croatia Croatia today is fully
integrated the European Union is the
country has done
very important progress and still you
know you have so many Creations uh
professionals youngsters moving towards
Ireland or moving towards Germany
because they want to get something more
and to get it now so this is uh it's uh
it's something that also is connected
with the fact that
everyone knows and in in and and these
kids that are coming from Albania they
know that in Britain there is a lot of
Need for construct construction workers
there is a lot of needs for taxi drivers
for truck drivers for nurses for so it's
also about this and uh and you know I'm
not here to question the the sovereignty
and the the Mandate of the British
government to have a policy on the
borders and to want to know to want to
be close towards uh towards uh the
fluxes that are attempting Britain for
uh to get a job
but this is all what it is about it's
about economic reasons coming getting a
job and building a future in a place
that has always been The Shining City on
the hill well yes and Albania was the
top nationality claiming Asylum as well
last year less of half of them were
granted Asylum and you have got a deal
haven't you but they claim Asylum
because there is no other way they are
not part of the of the Free Labor Market
uh which which for example is not the
case for Creations or is not the case
for Romania for bulgarians and so on
then on the other hand because of brexit
you know that uh some disruptions have
happened and you have lost a lot of
Workforce from these countries so it's
all about dreaming and hoping to get
what they imagine best for their life
now and to and without waiting for many
more years that this might happen in
Albania well yes but when they apply for
Asylum a lot of them aren't getting it
around half I think fail in their
applications and you do have a deal
between with Britain to send those back
how is that operating we have had a rise
we have had a rise in numbers uh in 2015
when the the large Refugee crisis hit
Europe
and it was a moment that a lot of
albanians went towards Germany and while
we fixed with Germany this safe origin
country uh uh category
the numbers went down so uh making
Asylum less less accessible for people
that are not really coming because they
have political
uh reasons or because they are
persecuted in their country or because
they are leaving a war but they are
using xylem to just get the possibility
to stay here and work is one of the ways
and Britain is doing it now so this is
one second we have to crack down uh the
the networks which are international are
not Albanian networks are international
and that's why it is very important to
separate uh the fight against Crime with
ethnic groups that cannot be labeled as
uh as uh feeding the crime the crime
world and on the other hand it's uh
about having a Visa system that give
access to people to apply in regular
Manner and to be processed without
taking the channel
coming here to work and come here to
offer their skills so this is a
combination of factors that is slowly
getting in place and I'm sure that uh
that this issue will be will be solved
but I'm not sure that uh closing the
borders and not letting people come in
is the best for the British economy but
this is not for me to to decide it's for
the British people okay well Eddie Rama
we appreciate you coming in and talking
to us today and do drop by again and let
us know the progress that you're making
and uh with your relations with the UK
as well thanks thank you very much I
hope to to welcome the prime minister in
Albania this is the first time that the
Nubian prime minister come to Britain
officially but we have not yet had a
prime minister coming to Albania
officially in our history Tony Blair
visited but it was because of the cost
of Kosovo war and hopefully we'll have
the prime minister of yours coming and
you will have you uh interviewing us
from Tirana that sounds like a good plan
when might that be I don't know I don't
know I don't know I I hope that we are
not gonna wait for another prime
minister to get the British prime
minister in Tirana okay well Eddie Rama
good to see you thanks very much indeed
thank you